[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
well it's a real pleasure to have this
trio with us today
um for for those of you know there are
many of us who have
had the pleasure of watching the larger
exit zero project which includes
a book a documentary film and the
project that we'll be seeing today
develop over the last few years and and
um
yeah so it's it's just exciting to see
what
um this this new part um how it's been
developing over the last year especially
um i i will go ahead and just
introduce everyone and then i'll hand it
over to
to the three of you so
uh jeff soyk is an award-winning media
artist with credits as creative director
and ui ux designer on pbs front lines
inheritance
which was a 2016 news and documentary
emmy
winner and a peabody facebook award
winner
as well as art director ui ux designer
and architect on hollow
which was also a peabody award winner in
2013
and a news and documentary emmy nominee
and was really you know one of the
the the first projects to really show
what was possible with
um interactive documentary um and
really kind of set a sort of high bar
early on in in the development of that
genre chris wally
is a professor of anthropology at mit
she is the award-winning
author of exit zero family and class
in post-industrial chicago which was on
university of chicago press in 2013
and a co-creator of a documentary film
exit zero
and industrial family story 2017.
chris babel is director of media and
development at mit open learning
where he oversees media production for
professional education
and explores the uses of media in
education
including vr and interactive media a
filmmaker by training he has produced
and directed feature films documentaries
and television
his work has been shown on many networks
around the world
including pbs and the bbc
and at more than 50 film festivals
including sundance
i will hand it over to the three of you
welcome great
thank you all so much and thank you
vivek for the
invitation um to come speak to
comparative media studies colloquium
um with vivec chris and i have been in
conversation for many many years because
our our projects um our work across
different media
has been ongoing for a long time so it's
been wonderful to be in conversation
on this whole time and so thank you so
much for the chance for us to come and
tell you a little bit about this latest
project that we're working on
um since you've already kind of gotten
quick introductions about who we all are
um maybe we'll just kind of hop into
things um
so today we're going to be talking about
a project we've been working on for a
number of years now called the southeast
chicago archive and storytelling project
and the way we were thinking that we
would organize um
the the discussion and demonstration
today is that as the project director
i'll give a bit of an overview of the
project
um and then we're going to kind of take
you through
and do a demo of the site um the site's
not fully completed we're hoping to do
our official launch um in the next month
or two
um but we'll um chris and jeff will lead
you through
the project we'll go back and forth and
talk more about
the larger overarching ideas as well and
hopefully leave a lot of time for the q
a and discussion
at the end because we're really
interested to hear what you all
make of this and again because we still
haven't officially launched yet we still
have a
chance to um you know take in feedback
and
make some tweaks so we would love to
hear what you all think
okay so just to hop in so this website
project is a club
collaboration on many different levels
on one level it's a collaboration
among ourselves chris jeff and myself um
as well as a large
and growing team of folks who've been
involved in this
um and i think jeff is doing the slides
there's another slide we have
too um that lays out
some of the folks who've been involved
in this project
and there's been quite a number we've
developed over the last 20 years we've
been working on this since 2004
in various different stages um so
there's there's the the kind of creative
team and academic team has been working
on it the three of us we also have
an archivist um a couple tech developers
we have advisory committee
um and a range of other folks who've
done various things for the project
but the biggest sense in which it's a
collaboration is with the southeast
chicago historical museum
um so what this is it's a little tiny
museum um in southeast chicago um
and basically the museum um
was created in the mid-1980s
um southeast chicago is part of the
caliber region which along with
southeast chicago and northwest indiana
was kind of the old
steel belt region in that area and the
steel mills started closing
in the 1980s and around that time that
the steel mills were closing
this little museum was created so it's
an all-volunteer museum
um it's located in one room in a park
field house along
lake michigan um it doesn't have a phone
much less the internet um it's
you know in some ways we think of it as
kind of like the community attic of
southeast chicago
um so it's an all-volunteer run
institution and it's been that way for
40 years now
basically um so with this little
community museum as the steel mill
started to close i mean i think
basically what happened was that a lot
of people who lived
in southeast chicago um who kind of felt
as the cmos were closing
not only that they were losing their
economic livelihoods but that also the
their history um and the kind of social
worlds in which they had grown up were
disappearing
and so i think there was a real sense
among a lot of people of wanting
to um you know hold on to or preserve
or do something with the kind of
materials of the past that they had
as part of their lives and make sure
that that continued or was recognized in
some way so there's a lot of donation of
material that happened
in the 80s and on from this region for
people in the community themselves
um and just to tell you a little bit
more about um
tell you a little bit more about the
community um so historically southeast
chicago
with the rise of the steel industry in
the late 1890s
a lot of the folks who came to live
there were european immigrants who came
to work in the steel mills
a lot of eastern european immigrants
around world war
one you started to get a lot of african
americans who are also coming to work in
the steel mills as well as mexican
americans
so it's a quite diverse region and it's
been that way historically
from some time um so
i think we also have um some video of
the museum itself just to give you a
little
a little taste of what the museum is
like
so this is this is um so this is the
museum as you can see again is one room
really overstuffed
um it's a pretty unique place it has a
really remarkable collection
um if we're getting some video like
maybe i'll
um turn off my video maybe that'll help
i'm not sure if that'll help with the
lag but
anyway um so it's a really kind of
unique place there's a
remarkable wealth of material in here um
there's about 180 oral histories that
dating back to the 1970s
there's about 10 000 images in the
museum about 350 pieces of film or video
about 250 pieces of clothing countless
documents and other materials
um and there's really not anything else
like this place that i know of i mean as
a scholar who works on
de-industrialization
and former industrial regions in
different parts of the u.s
there's not really anything else like
this a kind of collection of this much
material
that basically came out of the community
itself where the materials were donated
by people in the area
and if anybody's interested it's a good
question for the q a
how is it kind of how did this museum
emerge and how did it end up with such
an incredible collection over time
um but you know even though it's a
pretty amazing
um institution in a lot of ways um
you know again because it's in all
volunteer institutions it's only open
one day
a week um it's considered to be in a
very out of the way place within
chicago it's very difficult for people
to get there there's no public
transportation there
um and chris and i started working with
the museum for a book and documentary
film
um about the region which which phoebek
mentioned um exit zero exit zero is the
highway
exit ramp number for the old southeast
chicago steel mill neighborhoods
um and those works were more auto
ethnographic i grew up in southeast
chicago my father had been a steel
worker many
of my relatives had been steel workers
um
and so um that original work kind of
took that more kind of family oriented
as well as academic analysis to the area
and with this project we were really
trying to kind of spread it out and do
something different which you'll you'll
see as we go
as we go along um but so we got the idea
to collaborate with the museum in part
through cms's open dock lab um so
actually when chris and i were working
on the documentary film
um and in conversation with william
marichio and sarah
at the open doc lab um you know they're
saying well you know is there anything
about the research you should do
something
you know kind of idoc related um in
relation to your research and i was like
well i don't know about that but there's
this amazing museum that chris and i
have been working with
um and that actually was the original
impetus
to do this project and then we got
hooked up with jeff who has been a
fellow at the open dock lab
we knew about jeff's fantastic work with
hollow the the
interactive documentary that vivek
mentioned which was a
groundbreaking early one for those of
you who are familiar with in a really
fantastic piece of work
um and so we started working on this
project back in
2003-2004 and as the name
suggests um southeast chicago archive
and storytelling project is really meant
to be the project that we're creating
now
uh the website is really meant to be
both an online archive and a
storytelling
um site with a somewhat unique take on
both of those as hopefully
we'll demonstrate but i just wanted to
quickly tell you some of the larger
goals around the project
which we had going into this and so
those larger goals have been threefold
um first of all one of the things that's
quite important to me is an
anthropologist and somebody also who's
from
southeast chicago was to show the
diversity and the multi-faceted nature
of working-class lives
right so if in the kind of the trump era
the rhetoric around the working-class
quote-unquote
has been to resurrect this notion of the
way
of the class is kind of white male
industrial workers
i mean what this archive really does is
show that not only is that not the case
now
that also wasn't the case in the past um
folks in these industrial communities
were very diverse
there's a lot of diversity from early on
in racial ethnic
gender and other terms and so we're
really trying to capture some
um that kind of diversity of what the
working class quote unquote is and has
been historically
um and that doesn't mean that there
weren't very serious tensions within
this region there were certainly a long
racial and ethnic lines
um in part because the old um steel
mills the
steel mill management pitted very much
pitted ethnic and racial groups against
each other
um in order to decrease unionization and
so they're very real tensions and one of
the things we try to do is bring some of
those tensions into the website itself
um as you'll see but we also wanted to
highlight how the museum and the
material really kind of offers a more
multifaceted
view again of quote unquote working
class lives and history
so the materials in the museum not only
focus on
the steel mills or in work but also
people's social and cultural lives
um popular culture games music
and we also try to show i mean what the
materials themselves really demonstrate
and which we try to kind of capitalize
on
is that these kind of old communities
they also had very different kinds of
strains within those communities so both
quite conservative institutions and
quite progressive institutions another
case
this case is both kind of intertwined in
the in uh in these communities and so
we're really trying to capture this kind
of more multi-faceted view
of working class history and secondly
another goal of the project
um what we're really trying to do is use
objects that people in the region
themselves
saved and the stories that people told
themselves about those objects
to generate interest in working class
lives and kind of all its ethnic racial
and gender diversity
um and so this project is very much a
kind of anthro take on archives
so there's a real kind of fascination
with kind of what people saved from the
past so what do people donate to this
museum why did they donate it why was it
important to them
what were the stories that people told
through and about these objects
and what kinds of conceptions of history
emerge from this kind of storytelling
around objects
and the themes and the categories we use
to organize the website
largely emerge from the museum
collection itself and the way that the
volunteers
from the community themselves organized
on the museum
so for example there's one featured
curation
on kind of military experiences we call
it on the home front
um and you know thinking about the
military is not something i would have
come in
thinking about as an issue but there was
a lot of material
in this museum on people's experiences
either
people who had been in the military
themselves or people on the home front
and what that experience was like for
them
so that ends up you know being kind of
one of the focuses
um there so again we try to really draw
the themes and the categories from the
website from what's actually
in the museum itself and there's
something that's kind of cliche about
bringing history to life
but i really do think that telling
history through objects
really gives a more kind of lively sense
of everyday life
and the pleasures and struggles of
people's lives and many other ways of
telling history
um and i think this is particularly key
given that many of the issues
represented in the museum's collections
really speed speak to key issues in our
current in our current historical moment
as well
so things like the nature of work issues
of police brutality
ethnic and racial conflict controlled by
powerful corporate actors
and you really see all these kinds of
issues in the materials from the museum
um and how people how this played out
for people um
historically in this kind of region and
a third goal of the project is to
expand out our sense of who the audience
is so with this project we're really
trying for multiple audiences
obviously we'd like the general public
to be interested we hope to attract
teachers and students we're actually
working on a study guide
um to accompany this project um we want
scholars to be able to use it
but really the first audience in many
ways is people in the community itself
and in other deindustrialized um regions
like it
and so given my own background i've been
very concerned about being able to
interface with working-class audiences
particularly since for many people in
regions like this legit news is often
behind paywalls
local newspapers have been decimated
this area actually has the oldest
community
newspaper in the united states was in
southeast chicago
which has been down on for some time
there's no more local paid newspapers
that are left
and also disinvestment in public
education and so given this people
in the area themselves don't necessarily
know a lot about their own histories
often
um and how relevant the issues that
their forebears
struggled with um how relevant they are
to a lot of contemporary issues
and so we really wanted to engage with
diverse working-class audiences who have
links to this region or kind of other
de-industrialized ones
and to do it on a train generated by
community resonance themselves again
through the objects they saved and the
saved and the stories they told about
them
um so one of the goals of the project
for me anyways is to really think about
how to reflect back working class
history for working class
audiences of diverse backgrounds who
really don't necessarily get a lot of
that reflection back in many domains
today
and part of this goal is to use these
material to create bridges for
intergenerational conversation
so there's a scholar martha langford
who's argued that photo albums she
thinks of them not so much as pictorial
technologies
but as oral ones and she argues like if
you think about
albums photo of family photo albums and
how people actually use them
um they you know they pass them around
they talk to people
you know you sit down on the couch and
you'd chat with family members about
what was going on and the other people
who were
who were depicted in the photographs and
she really says them as conversational
objects that were mnemonic devices to
help people
remember um and so um
so so there was conversation built into
those kinds of albums and she argues
that when albums got put into museums
often the conversations at the heart of
those albums were suspended
and i was presenting on this work at a
conference not too long ago and a
colleague said
oh what you're trying to do in this
project is reanimate those suspended
conversations
um and in some cases in some ways to
engage in a kind of intergenerational
repair work
which i think is a really lovely way to
do it so how do we take these objects
that people in a community saved and the
stories around those and used those
to regenerate conversation that had been
there in the past
and kind of reanimate those links
between different generations
because for a lot of younger folks they
don't know much of this
history themselves so just quickly to
mention a couple challenges before i
hand it off to chris and jeff
so a couple of the challenges we faced
in putting together this archive and
storytelling project
um so number one because again this is a
tiny all-volunteer institution again
a bit more like a community attic in
some ways than a formal
museum um there's been no professional
archivist
um historically so record-taking taking
was really erratic
so different volunteers had different
numbering systems a lot of stuff
was never cataloged at all sometimes you
had handwritten records
um so it was really hard to even know
what all was in the museum
but how to find it um even for the
museum's
museum volunteers themselves who've been
working there for decades in some cases
and so when i was working on the first
neh grant for this back in 2013
we needed to know how many how much was
in the film and video collection because
we
wanted to ask for money to digitize it
but nobody knew so i like literally
spent like one day just
counting accounting vhs tapes you know
and then you'd go to a file cabinet and
pull out another drawer to be like oh my
god there's like six more 16 millimeter
you know reels of film here or you know
so so
at the beginning it was simply just also
a matter of just counting things
figuring out what was actually in the
museum um and then later we got money to
um when we got the nih money the first
thing we did was hire a part-time
archivist
i'm derek potts who's been fabulous um
and he's helped to
take these records and put them in an
online
database and also to help systematize
the records of what was there and create
ones for ones that didn't have records
so for the first time now you know not
only um
for us but also for the volunteers at
the museum they can actually see what's
in the museum
and one of the things that's been very
cool about that is as you can see
things and track now who's the donors we
can see how the different objects are
linked
because often people different family
members across generations often donated
things so you can put together now
different donations and figure out how
family members were were related or
linked together stories so it's actually
been really fantastically useful
and so just figuring out what's there
took three
three or more years of work to be able
to do that um a second major challenge
that we had
and this is true for all obviously all
archival collections
is thinking about the silences and gaps
in the archives so
in this particular case for southeast
chicago there's four neighborhoods that
are considered to be
part of southeast chicago um there was a
historical society founded in 1976 in
one of those neighborhoods
and that was largely a white ethnic
neighborhood um and
and that group was one of the kind of
founding
founding groups um but then this project
expanded out to four other neighborhoods
which were more diverse in
racial and ethnic terms um
but because of that kind of early
history and also because you didn't see
african-americans and mexican-americans
in the area until world war one
there's still a disproportionate amount
of material on white ethnics largely
eastern europe
eastern europeans um and another issue
that that came up also
is because of housing discrimination and
racism even though you had a lot of
african americans who worked in the
steel mills
and there's a lot of material on african
americans
in union history and in the steel mills
here
but because of that housing
discrimination they often didn't live in
southeast
chicago until later decades they often
lived in other parts of the city
and took public transportation so for
example we have a lot of material
again on african americans in the unions
but for example african-american
businesses
there's there's very little on that for
example so how to deal with that kind of
gap in the collection
so that was so what were the kind of
gaps in the silences in this
collection and how would we handle that
was another real challenge
um and then the last challenge i wanted
to throw out
um was this question of how to get
people excited and interested
in a place like this um thinking about
something like labor or industrial
history or working class culture
something like labor history people
often know very little about it
um these days pretty much in the 1990s a
lot of teaching of that at universities
often stopped um at that point um even
in the media you don't necessarily
you know kind of discussion about unions
is coming back but it kind of
went out of the picture for a while
there and again as i mentioned earlier
for a lot of young people even in this
area
um they really don't have a lot of
background
to bring to bear to help understand some
of the materials in the collection
um that deal with those kinds of topics
so how do you create ways in
to this material to allow people to
approach the archive
um and also on my end um
i was somewhat frustrated with some of
the other online archives that i saw
elsewhere sometimes they were
very beautiful sometimes very expensive
but sometimes they can be hard to
approach
so some of the online archives there
might be for example a lot of technical
information about oh here's a particular
object here's the exact
measurements here's the resolution that
it was scanned at but in terms of
what do we really know about the object
why did somebody save it who donated it
why did they care about this um so those
kinds of questions often aren't
answered in a lot of the archives um and
so that was another kind of challenge
was
how to um create pathways into this
material that would make it engaging for
people
would allow them ways to think about how
to how do you search for stuff
um how do you search for stuff if you're
not even aware of what you should be
looking for so how do we create pathways
in
when people might not know anything
about the area or the kinds of topics
that
that might be that might be interested
and then how do we do this
in a way that makes these materials
engaging
for people through the kind of metadata
we're going to bring about these
archival objects itself
so anyway so those were some of the
challenges and we're going to be talking
about later and then
in the talk about how we tried to
address those challenges in the website
itself
so now i'll hand it off to um chris
excuse me the noise in the background
who will then hand it off to
um to jeff thanks um
yeah i'm not sure what that was um so i
wanted to just say a few words about
um the museum collection itself and
storytelling because that's really at
the heart of the project
um so you know the thing that's really
unique
as chris mentioned about this collection
is how it was assembled it was assembled
by community members who basically just
donated things that were important to
them so there's not like a lot of you
know sort of
professionalization about it there's not
a professional archivist
it's not really programmatic you know
it's sort of like in
in in a moment of crisis this crisis of
de-industrialization
which is when when the museum started
this is what was important
to people this is what people felt they
needed to preserve
um so that means that there's some
pretty quirky items in the archive
um and there's you know there's a ton of
repetition um chris mentioned some of
the organizational challenges
um and you know there's a lot of you
know what some people might call junk
you know rod sellers who's the really
amazing volunteer
director of the museum who has a
historian's training
as a local community member and a
retired teacher
you know is always warning people like
don't bring your national geographic
magazines we don't want those
you know don't don't bring the contents
of your attic we're not going to sort
through
for you you know what you have um but
there are you know
amazing objects and and and some of the
objects you know some something that one
person might call
junk or trash is of course precious to
someone else
um you know like we have objects like
like these these are
baby shoes they were worn by a resident
named gloria heinkel novak was born in
1926 to german immigrant parents
she later worked as a secretary to
scientists working on the manhattan
project
at the university of chicago uh we have
this this is the last bar of steel that
was rolled
at republic steel in 1986
then called ltv steel um you know some
this was preserved because the workers
at at the mill
when it was being closed felt that it
was important to them
to to preserve it you know we have
thousands and thousands of photographs
and other documents these are the
martinez sisters this is this really
amazing
family of mexican immigrants mexican
americans
who were just incredibly dynamic
people who were real real pillars of the
mexican-american community
they'll come up later in some of the
stuff that we're going to show you um
but this is just this wonderful vibrant
shot of
the women of the martinez family
standing in front of st kevin's church
in south hearing one of the
neighborhoods
and you know this stuff is all mixed in
with other things
that some people might consider to be
[Music]
you know trash and some people might
consider to be amazing
but what really makes these things
amazing are the stories that connect to
them and the stories that people tell
about them
um you know they could be a story that
that's connected to the object directly
um it could be the story of how and why
it was donated
uh and who donated it um you know and it
could be
a story about how one particular object
in the museum is connected to
other objects in the museum all of those
are stories that we
are interested in exploring with this
site um
you know so so one of the chief goals of
the site is to find ways to connect the
objects in the archive with the stories
that they tell
so so it's it is an online archive first
it's an archive of digital objects
uh but what really makes the objects
powerful are these stories that we try
to tease out and
as you'll see there are sort of several
strategies or techniques
we've attempted to tell stories with
these objects
and to connect the archive itself quite
literally
with the objects and the stories that
are are behind them
the other point that i wanted to make is
that as chris mentioned this is
one phase of a multi-year multimedia
project
which we've called the exit zero project
and this idea
this technique or this um approach to
storytelling
comes really out of something that we've
been very passionate about for a long
time
uh the exit zero project as vivek
mentioned at the beginning
encompasses a book that chris wrote it
encompasses the documentary film that i
directed and chris and i coach produced
the documentary film in particular well
both both the book in the film
uh approached this trauma of
de-industrialization
that that happened in southeast chicago
uh beginning in the 1980s uh through the
lens or through the eyes of chris's
family uh
it is really a portrait of
uh chris's father who was a millworker
who lost his job
in a very very traumatic way in the
early 80s
as well as her mother as well as her
grandfather who also worked in the mill
there were several generations of
millworkers in her family um and of
chris herself
as as a daughter growing up in this
really tumultuous time
and that we found this to be a really
powerful way of telling stories to sort
of take the very particular lived
experiences of people
uh and then sort of you know connect
those up to these sort of larger social
and political political forces but to
really
try not to stray too far from the
experience but the
the the challenge or the downside is
that you know you've got the palette you
have to work with you have the people
you have to work with
uh chris's family's experiences are
their experiences
and so if we want to talk about other
communities
uh in the neighborhood african-american
mexican-american
other experiences other kinds of
experiences we don't really have a
window
into doing that if we're sort of staying
with her family
and what was really exciting was sort of
that moment when we
realized that the museum was that window
into a broader community and that we
could sort of try to apply some of the
same
techniques or some of the same things we
were doing in the movie to
this broader archive and so
so you know there are there are the
there is this sort of twofold
um uh twofold goal
or this two full challenge one being
just me
you know organize digitize and make
these objects available
because some of them are amazing and
really really incredible and
there's almost no way to view them
because it's this tiny room that you saw
but secondly to find the stories
within the objects or behind the objects
or between the objects
and connect those stories to these
larger
experiences the experience of
immigration the experience of racism
the experience of deindustrialization
and so this
site which jeff is going to introduce to
you is an attempt to
do both of those things so jeff i'll
stop sharing and you can take forward
okie dokie
all right so this is the home page
uh so as mentioned um
you know from the start of this project
uh you know our team discussed
that need for that this strong
relationship between archive uh
you know this archive of objects and
storytelling right
it's kind of like we wanted to really
have a strong connection between those
two things
uh and it was definitely from the
beginning it was desire to create
these kind of cinematic immersive uh
stories that incorporate the
uh the items from the archive um
which we ended up we ended up calling
these storylines uh
but so at the same time just in terms of
like the structure of this
as i'm kind of gonna go through the
homepage a little bit uh we're also
aware this website
actually um would probably function as
like a primary website for the museum
itself
uh and their archive so within this kind
of larger
archive and storytelling project
umbrella that we've created
which also obviously includes the exit
zero initiative
um so we did have a little bit of a
challenging uh you know kind of like a
brand challenge to kind of
overcome a little bit but ultimately we
decided to
kind of the way in was kind of
introducing this larger archive and
storytelling
project umbrella on the homepage
and then ultimately have the digital
archive
which is essentially kind of like the
home base for the museum
and these story lines that are stories
created using
you know items from the museum as their
kind of own independent sections
uh so you'll see in the beginning here
it's more you know kind of introduced
with a concept of
uh you know the idea of saving objects
and stories we tell about them
uh and also bringing up the idea of you
know who tells
uh who's in charge of history and all
and and obviously the importance of
everyday objects and kind of giving some
insight into
uh this uh community this former
industrial region
um and kind of you know i'm asking as
christine had mentioned earlier
you know whether kind of asking the
question of whether some conversations
can be sparked from these
from these objects uh you know across
generations and groups
and regions uh so kind of asking some
questions kind of sparking some
curiosity uh but
you know ultimately we've kind of just
kind of the site has kind of two main
sections in a sense it's the archive so
it's like the objects we save
uh this is kind of a way into that
and then the stories we tell so that's
the story lines kind of side of the
website
and this as you can that's mary flores
she's one of the residents that we
feature
in one of the stories
the rest of the homepage is more pretty
standard in terms of you know contact
and footer
[Music]
so you know even though they kind of uh
the story lines and the archive
uh kind of exist independently on the
site they do speak to one another
which we will show um
and also the archive itself does do a
little bit of work
and kind of pushes itself a little bit
to do a little bit more storytelling
than the typical archive which
you know christine will talk about uh
further
uh but i do i'm gonna jump into the
archive a little bit i'm not gonna get
into the details just yet
christine's gonna kind of take over but
um just in regards to
structure you know one thing that uh you
know christine mentioned earlier was
that
online archives tend to be you know kind
of off-putting to a lot of users why
they're structured because they can be
kind of overwhelming in their the broad
categorization that they use
uh or like you know just kind of hitting
was like a large search bar and they
just kind of
assume that you as a user that you know
what you're looking for
you know or um they assume that you're
like a researcher or or a scholar who
kind of uh already has something in mind
when you come to the site
so you know one of the challenges is we
definitely still want to accommodate
that type of user but we also wanted to
uh you know consider other ways in uh to
the contents uh so it's something that
christine will kind of get into further
detail about
i'll kind of jump in so like right off
the bat you can see
we have obviously our standard uh about
pages
you know so just kind of like about the
community about the project but also
about the
society and museum as well
so again it's kind of like multiple kind
of components to this larger
project
for those that kind of just want to jump
right to the archive we want to have an
easy access just browse option
so i will jump into that in a second
so this is kind of like as i was saying
like kind of a home base for the museum
itself this is almost like their
homepage
uh kind of like their their website in a
sense um
and uh christine will talk about the as
we scroll down
some of the uh editions that we kind of
added to it but
you know we really didn't want to just
hit with the you know the kind of large
uh search bar and kind of and again like
those kinds of like overwhelming
uh database terms and things like that
it's more
um we wanted to kind of introduce you to
it
give the option to quickly browse but
then also potentially
uh learn about what's in this collection
for someone who has
zero familiarity with it you know upon
visiting
so i'll just show
the archive i'm not going to dive too
deep but if i were to jump into browse
so this is so you know one of the um
challenges with this was that you know
we had to consider
uh kind of the scope and limitations
being this you know being an independent
team and trying to
we couldn't really necessarily reinvent
the online archive but uh and just
building an online archive
itself is quite a beast to un you know
to
take on but we figured uh what we could
do is kind of
build on top of it a little bit and
entertain some kind of tweaks and
additions
that would make us do a little bit more
and kind of speak to what
was mentioned earlier about trying to
tease out the kind of story aspects of
these objects
uh so this is more the kind of you know
kind of conventional foundation of the
archive itself
uh as you can see there's close to a
thousand objects
entered uh to date
which required an enormous amount of
work from all of us
but um definitely chris christine and
the archivists
a lot of work uh putting these together
uh we chose to there's a right now
there's a tab on the side
that allows you to filter by different
criteria
uh there also will be we do have a
search bar that's programmed
that is hidden uh currently only because
we have to do more work on the kind of
metadata side
and keywording side of things to make
that search bar really function
at its full capacity uh so there will be
a search bar here but
we intentionally kind of put it off to
the side and want to hit you know it
didn't want to hit you with that first
as like the uh the main way in
uh but uh currently in this development
version
you know you can filter by various
themes
and see themes we also have you know a
lot of have sub themes as well
so you can get pretty specific in terms
of the
kind of topics uh you want to dive into
also time periods
organized by neighborhoods ethnicity and
race
and also media type
um so so just uh one thing to also keep
in mind that we were thinking about when
building this was that this is something
that
um is ultimately going to be kind of
passed to
the museum volunteers we think about
long-term maintenance
and also them kind of using this as a
tool uh so you all you know
you also don't want to make this
something that they can't navigate
themselves
and can't also keep up with them
uh so this is so the strategy was to
kind of incorporate some additions to
the common archive
um you know and also and also knowing
that you know as we considered
different ideas on how to handle the
archive content that also
kind of creates new work for either
ourselves
or the museum volunteers you know which
uh
you know christine can talk about a
little bit more in terms of some of the
things that we came up with
there they definitely help bring out
some of the story elements of these of
this collection of this archive
but it does require you know additional
research to be done additional work to
be done
and and like content to be created and
generated
uh to be added so we kind of approach
this as like a little bit of like a
you know stepping this thing forward
kind of a little bit of a time at a time
and kind of trying out a few things
uh and things that we can kind of test
get some responses uh from
uh and kind of see what's even feasible
uh in terms of like
the kind of workload that we're uh
potentially
promising um so yeah so we feel like
that's kind of the smartest way to
approach it creatively and structurally
um but uh but chris um i'll pass on to
you she'll get into the details of
some of the kind of additions that we
added to it
okay thanks jeff here let me
so sorry can everyone see that
yep okay okay great
um so just in um in relation to this
question of
um in relation to this question of how
to deal with gaps and silences in the
collection which i talked a little bit
about earlier
um so how to deal with this and as i um
raised the question um about you know
for example
um since there are fewer materials on
african-americans
particularly in terms of you know sort
of community life
um how do we um
highlight those those materials more um
in the collection so
you know if there's a preponderance you
know there's more on say eastern
europeans
how do we make sure that that stuff
doesn't get kind of lost um
you know lost in the sea of other things
um and so one of the
the ways we try to address this in the
archive
um i'm sorry i'm gonna go future
curations
uh back to the future curations list um
so one of the ways we try to address
this is by creating
um what we call to uh call this featured
curations we have 13
of these so basically curating on
certain topics
things that were key to life in
southeast chicago
but there might be fewer items on those
things
in in the museum but they're things that
we think people would be interested in
and so we created these um featured
curations
um this one here is on black experience
in the mills um
we have another one on women at work i
mean one of the things that often
happens in industrial communities
because
there's a lot of focus say on steel
labor it tends to focus on men's work
um and doesn't acknowledge as much there
were some women who did work in the
mills
both during world war ii and then
beginning in the 1970s
but there was other work that women did
both in the mills um
in offices for example here or in other
kinds of
work so we have a featured curation on
women at work so that kind of doesn't
get lost
um we have one on on the cradle of the
game
the cradle to the grave i'm thinking
about sort of the life
course for many people in the area
and trying to curate some objects that
relate to that again some of these are
oral history some of them are objects a
lot of things are photos
um we have one on union life
we have one on danger in the mills the
mills were quite dangerous
as i think many people probably know
there's one on just having fun there's a
lot of material on um
just sports and popular culture and
um you know so we wanted to make sure
that that had um
had a place um a key place on the site
as well
um because this was historically a
largely immigrant
community um in a lot of ways so we
wanted to kind of pull some of the key
materials around that up towards the
front as well
so anyway so we have 13 different uh
featured curations
and that's one of the ways then to try
to kind of both
um create ways for people to be able to
approach this site
um but also to make sure that certain
kinds of materials weren't getting kind
of lost
um um getting lost
overall uh and to give you so here um
for example
um since again we have we
have relatively little material um on
african-american home life we wanted to
make sure that we prominently emphasize
this one
these are the home movies of a family
called the elkins family
um and it's quite telling so this object
in the back story
um which i'll get to in a minute what
that is but we have these
um descriptions of the objects again for
a lot of african-american steel workers
because of housing discrimination they
didn't actually live within southeast
chicago
so for example this family robert elkins
was the first african-american
boilermaker at u.s steel south works
but his family lived actually in a
housing project in bronzeville in
another section
of chicago again because of housing
discrimination so this is actually
home movies from there so we try to use
the kind of stories around the
particular objects to talk about the
issue then say housing
housing discrimination for example um
and then what happened then with a lot
of the housing developments in chicago
they when they changed their
um their standards for um how much money
you can make and still
live in them a lot of african
african-american steel workers got
kicked out of housing developments and
so then they had
to find housing elsewhere which was um
you know again very difficult for them
so housing became
becomes a real kind of question so we
try to use this object of the home
movies
as a way to talk about those kinds of
questions
so and let me just go back to
sorry i'll just i'll just do it this way
so we have um featured curations um is
again a way to kind of approach
um this collection for um users we also
have at the very top something called
featured items
um and so these featured items
[Music]
you know one of the questions then too
is when you have
um certain items
i'm sorry i'm trying to get to a
particular item which is quite an
amazing one this one for example
um that's particularly um that we really
want users to focus on say how to again
not
get have it gets lost in the shuffle so
we
so the featured items are just rotating
items that we want to highlight
for users at various points and this um
this one here
was a world war one diary um and again
it's another example of sort of things
being lost in the museum there was a
note in the record that there was a
world war one diary of polish
but nobody could find it um and at some
point just like a year or so ago
somebody pulled open another file
cabinet and they found
um this world war one diary um um in the
bottom of it
um and so it's half written in polish
half written in english it's a really
interesting piece this guy actually he
was a polish
american immigrant who actually joined
the polish army um during world war one
um the u.s allowed polish americans to
join the polish army and then they
trained in canada and actually got sent
to france to fight
um but anyway so it's half in polish
it's half in english we had to find
somebody who could translate it which
was hard because a lot of it's archaic
polish
um but it's interesting too this guy was
also interested in poetry so there's
snippets of poetry and kind of drinking
songs in polish
but also it appears to be some poetry
that he himself
wrote um so we had this translated
um and you know and again we can tell
through the archival donations
um this guy had worked in the packing
houses and he married a polish young
woman
whose family all worked in the steel
mills and he came to live in the steel
mill area
i mean this was later donated by a
family member um so anyway so we could
use these featured items there's also
another one
um about um there was a midwife a
croatian midwife
who had her midwife records going back
from the 1910s and 1920s all written in
croatian
so anyway so we're using the featured
items and the featured curations as a
way to draw attention
again why um and
sorry um so there's also um
an idea of story pass which i think
we're going to kind of hold off on
thinking about that now into a bit later
but another major way again
is in different kinds of ways is
something called um the story lines
um which jeff and chris are going to
talk about but actually they're sorry
there's one thing
that i've forgotten to show which i
meant to
my apologies oops sorry um
i just wanted to quickly show um
something that we refer to as
backstories
let me find an example um so
you know again how to um
approach these objects in a different
way so this was an id
badge um from u.s steel southworks um
and so this woman pasquale martinez
she's the mother of actually
the five young women in that photo that
chris showed earlier um
and so when when we're we're giving
descriptions of these things what we're
trying to do then
is write up what we're referring to as
backstories um so
it's we're trying to have it be a bit
more than the usual kind of context
that's given and try to have it be a
little more
personal um partly it depends on what we
have in oral histories but basically
we've been taking oral histories
other information in the archives doing
research on ancestry.com
on some sometimes secondary literature
also we've been going to people in the
community the museum has a facebook page
with about six thousand
people so for particular items you know
we'll post it on the facebook page and
like does anybody know this person do
you know anything about this kind of
object or what's being depicted
um and we're getting information back
and we're kind of creating these little
kind of summer um some of these
backstories
are quite long others are relatively
short
but we we try to link it up um
through the ways people talked about um
or reference the objects which are also
often through families
and family connections this is a quite
simple one um
who is a woman who worked in world war
two also in the steel mills
um so again we're trying to use these
backstories as a way to talk about the
objects and the donors
and you didn't really see that in these
two examples but for in cases where we
have oral histories which have been
trying to pull directly
um comment comments from the world
histories themselves or
stories um that people told
um and actually pull those stories and
and um quotations from the oral
histories into the discussion of the
objects themselves
um okay so i think maybe i'll hand it
over to chris and jeff here for
um discussion then about the storylines
okay thanks um so
let me
share my screen
um so to this point
um you know as jeff mentioned uh
the site is really divided into two
sections there's the archive which is
um the objects we save that's kind of
how we were describing that
and then there's the stories we tell and
all of the things that chris has
been talking about so far are all
part of the archive part of the art the
objects we save quote unquote
uh so those are a number of strategies
for
telling those stories and connect making
those connections that i i was talking
about before
um but one of the the chief ways that
we're we're attempting to do that
is in the other part of the website uh
the stories we tell
and this is where we're putting together
what we call story lines which
are basically broader more sweeping
or sort of more significant stories
uh that are told entirely with objects
from
the archive and to date we've completed
one and we're in the middle of doing the
second
the first one which jeff and i are going
to just talk about very very quickly
is called mexican american journey and
it's about
the mexican-american experience over you
know
a century essentially uh in the
neighborhood
it ties obviously to other immigrant
experiences
there are a lot of commonalities but
there are also a lot of things that are
very different
about about the mexican-american journey
so each of these each of these stories
begins with an object and
in this case the object is uh this
display of dog tags uh replica dog tags
these are the dog tags that belong to
the young men who died in vietnam from
the
our lady of guadalupe parish the
local catholic parish that was primarily
mexican-american
and in fact more young men from that
parish were killed in vietnam than from
any other parish in the country
so they suffered very very heavily
during the vietnam war
and this object which is part of the
museum collection becomes a springboard
for our attempt to explore this this
mexican-american experience over many
generations
so we we uh introduce the object we
learn a tiny bit about it uh and then
uh the first thing that we do in each of
these stories is we meet someone
who um has a connection to the object
might be the creator it might be someone
who has a very significant
story that relates to the object in this
case it's not the creator it's mary
flores
um who is a woman whose brother
uh was killed in vietnam and in fact one
of these dog tags is his
so um we start with a very short video
of mary which i'll
i'll see if it will play i know all the
young men that passed away at our lady
of guadalupe
even father maloney he said he says i've
never seen so many
of a young men from a parish die
yeah but my brother was the first one
that was killed and that's him like
rubbish there
they all from our neighborhood all from
south chicago
my name is mary e flores and i've been
in chicago
since 1949. when i first came to chicago
i didn't like it because i'm from
oklahoma uh my father used to be a coal
miner
and he lost his job we came here and all
the steel mills were
going there and the coke plant and
everything it was so ugly and you see
all that graphite flying around
i told my mother i don't like the city i
like the being on a farm instead you
know she said
she told me oh you're crazy there were
17 of us
because i was second to the oldest i
remember i used to carry the kids on my
hip
and do their diapers and all of that and
hang clothes and take them down
and chase after the kids
that's my brother tony he was the oldest
and now he was killing korea at the age
of 17.
joseph was one of my younger brothers
and then he went into vietnam
and then he was killed in january 1966.
oh my god my mother and she she she was
beside herself because she had already
lost one son in korea
now the second one she wasn't herself
anymore after that
the year we give them birth and they're
taken away and they don't come back
we got a lot a lot of military family
three of them didn't make it though
you know they wanted to fight for our
country so they did
it's just something that they're proud
that they're proud to be an american you
know
from here we broaden out to the
community and this is a mural that's
painted on the wall of a building
right by the church and the church is
really the center
of the community you can see the spire
um so so we move out from there
to um and i'm not going to go through
painstakingly um but we we move
to to tell this story about mexican
american immigration that
uh attempts to sort of get at uh
you know the place of the
mexican-american community mexican
mexican immigrants
in america and uh racism
the sense of patriotism the sense of
belonging or not belonging
uh over as i said over 100 years
and all of the objects in the story are
from the collection
and you can always actually find them in
the collection with this tab here
so if i click this i would go to the
archive entry of this particular drawing
so we have all sorts of objects here
we have you know linking text we try to
do it only when needed uh but obviously
we're trying to
to um to sort of connect make
connections sometimes
uh hundreds of oral histories there are
hundreds of oral histories in
in the museum and these uh storylines
draw very heavily
on oral histories um
so jeff do you want to go look at or
talk about any particular
part of this um
yeah no i think i mean you covered a lot
of it we really are we're just trying to
kind of create a nice um
you know thoughtful flow and you know we
kind of obviously had to kind of work
through
a story uh kind of outlining process
and then also considering a lot of the
media as chris mentioned there's so much
to pull from and
uh you know christine was trying to kind
of distill a lot of what what is there
and then we have to kind of and then you
know let's try and put this into uh
you know a story with with an arc that
can that we could we actually had like
visual media and things that we could
make use of but we also you know we had
a sound designer
uh billy rasnick who uh he
you know pulled from actual videos from
the archive as well like at one point we
have some parade sounds and he got that
from a
mexican-american parade that was in the
archive they were able to use for
some of the atmospheric uh soundscapes
this is our lady of guadalupe this is
the church that i talked about at the
beginning and we're hearing a service
in the church right so it's like an
actual church service
that was recorded uh by someone on the
ground there
uh we weren't able to travel there um
ourselves so we ended up hiring someone
who was local
to record that sermon there
so so yes it's kind of you know it's a
mixture of uh
mostly driven by materials from the
museum but then kind of complemented by
some original texts and sound design and
some
original you know some video work and
some other pieces of media
i showed the photo of the martinez
sisters early so this is a really
really great rich oral history that they
that they did
quite a few years ago that's part of the
collection
so anyway so the story you know we again
we're not going to sort of go
go through it point by point but um
it goes it goes through the sort of long
journey of of
this community and and the sort of
moments when they flourished in the
moments when they faced all sorts of
challenges
um and then at the end we end with mary
flores again
um i don't know if i'll show that video
or not
um it might be it'll take too long
chris is like if you open the menu uh
you can't
open the menu yet no the uh menu
yeah so if you can click close that menu
via the tab oh yeah all right right
so this is um this is again a very
important part because as i said you
know we want to link
these stories with the archive itself so
here you can see
you know these are the the objects that
make it up these are the ones that we've
already
experienced and then you actually see
you know they're grayed out right now
because we haven't gotten to them yet
but those are
objects to come in the in the story so
you can jump back to
you know any of these pictures any of
these oral histories
or other objects and if you click i mean
you should click on view item in archive
and you can just show that it yeah
you know will launch it we'll go to that
item in the archive right so we're
kind of allowing the user to decide
whether or not they want to deep dive
into any of those items and spend time
with it in the archive
before returning back to the story right
and then
you know in in the archive there might
be a backstory there might be some other
element that you know chris has already
talked about
so that's this is the one that we've
completed um we have three more that
we're working on
and one of them the next one that we're
working on that we have
roughed out is about
a very very important event that
happened in labor history
in the area the memorial day massacre
that occurred in 1937
on memorial day when um 10 steel
striking steel workers were were shot
and killed during a peaceful protest uh
during what was essentially called a
police riot at the time
they were just gunned down by the police
so
we don't have a lot to show you but we
do have
the opening video and i think maybe we
can end with that
the the object that everything springs
out of this is a really really amazing
object it's
a scrapbook that was put together
by a young woman whose uh fiancee soon
to be husband
was one of the strikers and you know uh
people who grew up in the midwest may
remember
their moms grandmas great-grandmas
making scrapbooks often they're about
weddings or
you know birthdays or funerals or big
life events
christenings this one is a scrapbook
about a massacre
and um it's a really really powerful
object
so jeff do you should we just show the
mike borison video and then kind of end
there
sure um so you if you have that here
i'll stop sharing
okay
so this is just kind of like a rough
early pass so it actually looks a little
different than the
mexican-american story even though it's
going to follow the same format
kind of skip through the text here but
same idea and then introducing
starting with objects so in this case
it's a scrapbook
and then kind of transitioning to a
resident that has some kind of personal
connection to that object
so in this case it's mike borzan whose
mother made the scrapbook
and we'll jump into his video
um actually know it just do make sure i
have the uh
computer sound here
okay
my mom kept a good book
sad day sad day
this is where i grew up as a kid it's on
uh
117th in buffalo this dirt road still
looks the same as it did when i was
growing up here
a pear tree right here
and the steel mill was right there when
we lived here my dad would walk to work
there used to be a brick factory over
there
but i guess when the 1937 strike hit
this was all prairie except for the few
houses that were here
and from i remember from that day is
what my mom and dad told me
they were pickling the steel mill all my
family was here my mom my dad my uncles
they were all here because they wanted
to form the union and back in them days
you know they had no rights as as
workers
then all the as my dad would say the
bulls come running down the hill with
their night sticks
shooting people beating people and
they say got pretty violent they seen uh
many of their friends getting hit with
the billy clubs
seeing a couple of the people that died
falling next to him that was 1937
memorial day
yeah all this all this happened right in
here
so that's the field where the massacre
actually occurred which was
right next to his mom's house when she
was growing up
um so chris do you want to just kind of
wrap up for a couple minutes and then we
can do questions
um yeah i mean
just to kind of leave time because we
don't have a lot of time i think
um the best i think to kind of just jump
into the q a
um but just to just quickly um you know
a final thought you know again
this whole project has been very
collaborative um
in a lot of ways and built on
interaction with the community
in the website itself there's not a lot
of space for people to like say add new
stories or other things
not because we didn't want to have that
but because the people the volunteers at
the museum were afraid of being
overwhelmed with stuff and work
um and they already have this facebook
group that has like six thousand people
so they're asking us to send the traffic
of people who want to talk or donate
things
over to the existing facebook page
that's already there
um but in other ways you know i mean
again it's been collaborative from you
know in terms of
you know who donated the stuff um how
it's built on the museum and the
community itself you know going back to
folks in the community to talk about
what these objects mean to them
um um you know pulling on their
knowledge about these materials
for our backstories and other materials
um and
and you know the plan for the future
we're working right now in a study guide
for teachers in the area and others
and the whole idea again is to spark
community conversations
um right so this is meant in some ways
be again you know a prompt for
conversation back and forth um both
within the area and also with people
um and other regions as well um so
that's
you know kind of the next stage after we
have the official launch and get this
stuff finished
is the next stage is again getting back
to collaborative work with the community
kind of using this tool to spark a range
of conversations so
um you know we don't exactly know where
that's going to go yet but um but but
that's the that's the plan
and we've done that with the exit sphero
book and film um where we have
had a lot of community screenings of the
exit zero film and
they've been very powerful in some ways
because often people would kind of
get up and kind of witness their own
family's experiences of the
industrialization
and so we're hoping that this one again
because it's kind of so spread out a
range of different families and their
stories and
individuals and different neighborhoods
talking about what their experiences
were coming in some cases from very
different positions
um using that as a you know kind of
prompts again to be people
getting people to reflect on their own
history um
so anyway so um please let's open it up
for conversation and apologies for
um not having more time for the q a
because we'd really love to hear what
you all
um are thinking
thank you so much um
i usually jump in and ask a question
taking advantage of
my status as host but i'm not going to
do that i do have
questions but i wanted to just open it
up more broadly to everyone
laura i want to thank you for your
presentation um i'm i'm actually from
wisconsin and so
this just felt it felt close to me and
just kind of my experiences also growing
up in
around the communities um some some
similar to this
so um the design of the
website just looks elegant and
accessible and i really appreciate
the measures you took to make it that
way my question for you which you
somewhat answered already um is that it
sounds like you're designing tools
for teachers to use um but have you ever
seen this being used pedagogically
already has the community already taken
it in certain ways
um besides showing the film taken this
and already begun to use it as a
teaching tool
um because i just think it's incredible
and i'm kind of curious to see
what they've already come up with if
they have
um we're working on the study guide
right now and in conversation
with some community leaders about you
know interfacing
with teachers in the public schools and
how we might
want to use this as a disseminate it
within the community
also through you know a lot of people
one of the things that's tough about
this
a lot of people in the area have phones
and the archive itself works well on
phones
these story lines are very data
intensive
um so that's going to be an issue for
people who don't have laptops so we
really want to try to get it out through
the community through the schools then
for where for example where people would
have more access to laptops
or the local public libraries which a
lot of people go
rely on those heavily to be able to
access computers so trying to do kind of
um community viewing events at the
library
you know both kind of community events
and then having people kind of give
their feedback on stuff
um so um that's all still it's sort of
in process yet so we don't fully know
yet exactly
um how it's going to be taken up but
we're
we're hopeful that um people will
make real use of it
amber hi thank you so much for your
presentation it's really impressive uh
all the work
that you have been doing uh in the
archive and i was wondering if you
have considered expanding the archive to
and bring it to the present you know
like i i saw that you were interviewing
people
but then i was wondering if those people
also have stories right and also have
like
important objects so if you start like
collecting those
and expanding the story it could create
like a
broader picture of the whole town i know
it's a lot of work but i guess
i was just wondering uh yeah
yeah i don't know if um if chris has
other thoughts on this as well but
the other two storylines that we want to
do one is about the impact of the
industrialization the loss of the steel
industry on the community and the last
one is on environmental activism
um there's a lot of industrial pollution
so the environmental activism story goes
up into the contemporary period so like
you see you see where that um
the the memorial day massacre strike
happened that's now a brownfield
that's toxic there's a lot of space in
southeast chicago that's just toxic
empty brownfield
um so community environmental activists
um
in the area so so that's a storyline
that goes up to the current moment
um so and we do want this become
to become a site where it's both about
the past but using the past as a way
again to connect generations and think
about the future what do you what's the
future
for old industrial communities like this
um
so we would love to think that you know
about you know some of the stuff
you know you're suggesting about you
know if
you know again we have to work with the
community volunteers because they don't
want to be overwhelmed so how to do it
in a way where you can take in more
you know maybe if some people end up
volunteering where we can kind of think
about creating other kinds of ways then
to access newer material and attach it
to the site
um so that's something um you know we'd
like to think about moving forward
i don't know if chris or jeff if you had
other um well i would just say yeah so i
was
the environmental activism story that
that storyline
the um the object that it comes out of
is a jar of pet coke peck coke is a
toxic material that's left over from oil
refining
uh tar sand oil refining and and so that
was collected a couple of years ago by
a bunch of relatively young activists
a lot of them are moms who have children
who live in the community
who who become very very adamantly
opposed to some of the more recent
you know there's a long history of toxic
pollution in the area but
the more recent sort of uh uh you know
uh levels of it so so yeah we
we are very interested in bringing it
into the contemporary period but
it is a it's an enormous amount of work
and it's all volunteered
you know the museum is all volunteers so
um
you know we are are assisting in the
organizing and
and so on of the collection the
collection remains the communities
thank you um there are a couple of
questions in
in chat um so i'll go
to to those for a moment um
so from from greg curious about how you
hope
members of the community use the online
project to share their oral stories
with family and friends as they would if
sitting on a couch while thumbing
through
an old family scrapbook photo album how
do you hope they recreate that shared
social experience
well yeah i mean i think that's a great
question you know one of the
one of the issues that we have right now
which
you know is a huge you know it's a huge
developmental lift
is the fact that um the story lines
don't work particularly well on phones
they're quite glitchy
um so the archive as chris said
is better uh you know i think i i would
like to think that
you know people that huddle around a
laptop uh we know that in practice that
doesn't always happen
um phones are really kind of the center
of social
the social world for a lot of people and
it's more virtual it's not like sitting
on the couch
together necessarily although although
our son does that with his friends
um so you know i can very easily imagine
people sharing this on a phone
uh either when they're in the same space
or in different spaces
uh the laptop which of course as mit
people we all have
uh is less of a you know common item
we'll say though i mean we are looking
at this work on tablets it's more just
like for the storyline part right the
archive itself is definitely mobile
friendly
yeah right blue line uh the thing is
it's kind of like
uh you're doing a service to users if
you expect them to download all that
media on their data plan
on a phone you could blast someone's
data plan pretty quickly
so but i mean if you're on wi-fi with a
tablet that is certainly a potential
option
so that could be more conducive to what
you're describing
and something else we had talked about
but again we were kind of overwhelmed
with how much work it would take but
would still be a great idea
is if you can put the gps coordinates in
for the various
objects and yeah because there's a lot
of old photos or particular places
because then i could
definitely see a lot of people with
their phones walking around to various
parts of the neighborhood that might
have been like
you know because like the site we didn't
show this but at the end of the the
mexican-american journey story
you go back to the southwest which was
the biggest mill in that area
which is now all brownfield and so you
actually at the ruins of the brownfield
they actually had a recent
day of the dead event um where um
mexican americans in the community were
honoring their ancestors who had worked
in
in the museum so that's pretty powerful
there at the ruins so you could see
people with their phones and rooms like
that
looking up the images of the time period
um but again that you know getting all
the gps data and setting that up it's
you know
time and money um so we have lots of
things we'd love to do
if we had and just one last one
one last point about it so because of
de-industrial industrialization and the
economic challenges that the area has
faced for you know
the last more than 20 years uh there's
been kind of a diaspora
of of people you know a lot of people
have moved away but who
still feel really tightly connected to
the area
so there as chris mentioned i think
there's a really strong
facebook presence that the museum has a
very very lively facebook group
people are always commenting always
sharing things
so um i think that the archive part
and hopefully the storylines as well as
you know on tablets or laptops
can kind of be taken up into that
diaspora ecosystem so that
people are kind of doing what they might
do with a photo album
but doing it across you know great
distances
and i just want to say in relation to
one of the other questions in the chat
about relationships with other
chicago-based institutions that have
archives and museums so the advisory
there's an advisory group for this
project it includes somebody from the
chicago history museum and the field
museum
and so they've been fantastically
helpful
in all of this um and actually with the
guy
um we've been working with the chicago
history museum he actually
has his phd in um in slavic studies so
he's volunteering to translate some of
the serbian and croatian materials
for us which is which has been fantastic
um so we are in connection with those
folks and they actually through the
field museum they're trying to create a
consortium of institutions
across the calumet region to bring
together different kinds of archival
collections this is kind of like the
biggest one but there's a number of
other kind of small
historical historical collections and
gary indiana also has
um some industrial archives there so
trying to create a kind of a consortium
of groups as well and then hooking
them up through the field museum in the
chicago history museum so
more users can find um those spaces
um so we are trying to kind of connect
create those connections
also folks at the um mexican museum of
art
in south um um in southwest chicago
um as well
hey looking at the chat i see that
there's a question about the curation of
the story lines and the creation of them
and just because that's like a very
challenging process i don't know if we
want to
say a couple of words about that i don't
know jeff you're
you're kind of always uh you know like
like shouldering the burden there i
don't know if you have anything to
say uh to answer that one
well it might have to be articulated the
question it sounds to me like it might
be more about
um it's like choosing the materials to
use and
whose voices are heard so like what
yeah kind of the uh the selection
process right the media
and the materials that we're using right
which i think relates to the narrative
process
broadly speaking which is also
challenging yeah absolutely
yeah i mean it's a narrative process but
i guess i'll also say it's also
um you know plays into like christina if
you want to talk about
she you know how you're sharing this
with the committee and and you know
various community members that are
getting incorporated into these stories
as well so there's that part of it too
and and just to say with as part of um
from the beginning of the project and
also as we were working on the
grants for the national endowment
humanities we worked with the advisory
community which has community reps and
the different volunteers from
from the different volunteers on the
board of the museum
um you know and we we kind of talked
through and
you know we tried to pick stuff based on
what's
in the museum itself you know so again
trying to honor the kind of categories
that people had in terms of like
you know there's certain topics that you
know again the military topic there's a
ton of stuff
so as an anthropologist that's really
interesting why is there so much stuff
on the military here so that's been an
interesting one to ponder so we've tried
to kind of honor
the kind of categories around which
people were donating stuff
but then another instance is we tried to
like if we knew for example
by the time the steel mills ended about
a third of the workers
were white again largely eastern
european about a third were mexican
american about a third were
african-american
um and turn you know so we
you know but again there's there's some
gaps within the museum's collection
itself so in those cases where we know
that it's kind of reflective of the
actual social life of the area
trying to make more prominent certain
voices that might be getting lost
in the stuff because we know that's
historically accurate
um to the place and so that played a
role as well so we went through
with the advisory committee what is this
stuff we want to prioritize and
emphasize
and how do we kind of create balance in
these kinds of ways both honoring
kind of what people donated and why they
thought it was important but also making
sure that we're addressing gaps if gaps
are there so we went through that kind
of process then of
um deciding what kind of stuff to
emphasize and then jeff had a huge
um influence as well as like kind of
what stuff is arresting
in aesthetic terms um that we you know
that people would
you know enjoy looking at which was
definitely part of the process as well
if you've got
300 pictures of a steel mill right which
which ones are the exciting ones to look
at and
anyway
i'm going to take another question from
the q a
this is from mimi who asks this
or who says this is an awesome project
thank you so much
can you show an example of an entry on
the back and
i don't know whether jeff you're set up
to do that
and if not it would it would certainly
be interesting to
to hear a bit about the
code side of this back end yeah i mean
so this is built on wordpress
uh so any of you have used wordpress
it's pretty
pretty standard you know it's customized
and everything i have our back and
developer jared
um you know i could when i could try
pulling it up real quick
um the story lines
are very custom that's not really
anything that we have like a back end
for because that's like a very tailored
thing we've been kind of creating and
kind of shaping
as we make them uh so that's something
we're just kind of building
manually um and it's just a map it would
be a massive thing to like making a
platform from scratch uh so we just
don't have the kind of resources
resources and capacity to do that the
story lines but for the
archive side we definitely
you know it's all wordpress based so i
can do
quick
jump in here
so here's your typical you know
wordpress dashboard um
we have a feature curation section uh we
have our
here's the archive let's jump into there
so if i just jump into one of the
individual entries
um this is actually speaking to another
piece of software called archive space
that the museum's using to kind of
catalog everything in there
in the archive uh so the archivist
derek works very much with those records
he's like a session records in the
archive
and he inputs a lot of the metadata
there and then we're actually putting in
the unique id
from those records and that's actually
drawing from archive space and pulling
in that data
into wordpress so we actually do have
two kind of
databases that are speaking to each
other for this project
and then we have the ability to kind of
add additional metadata on top of that
uh
and then you'll obviously articulate if
it's like if this item is a part of
future curation
if it's a part of the story line we can
add a call to action for the storyline
that's a part of
add any kind of rights information you
know put up the thumbnail
if it's it's something we have on
youtube it's a piece if it's a video we
have a link to the youtube video
on the channel and then of course you
know all the filters and everything are
these check boxes on the right hand side
so how how are those two integrated the
the
the database that you're pulling from
that there
is that um custom code that you're
writing
manually or is there is there
some existing um you know plug-in or you
know how much of it is
is sort of you know pushing beyond what
what wordpress allows you to do and kind
of customizing it in a very
um you know line-by-line way
yeah well i mean you know wordpress is
pretty pretty much applying canvas in
terms of like just a foundational
framework
and then so this is definitely
customized but um
uh you know in terms of some unique
functionality the fact that it is
pulling so archive space has an api
so that allows it to you know kind of
make its data accessible to external uh
programs so we're tapping into archive
space api to draw from its data to pull
into here
uh and then there's gonna there's like
an automated kind of
check uh you know the frequency we have
get to the decide but it might be like
every
week or so where wordpress will look
back to archive space and see if
anything has changed
and automatically make updates um you
know but the main unique relationship
here is that archive space really would
be the place where the museum would go
to kind of organize their collection and
keep keep tabs on it
and be able to find things uh and then
this
the wordpress and this website is more
like once they decide they want to
feature something in a digital archive
and make it more public
that's when it kind of you know leaps
over to this website
and becomes a new headed item to this
because obviously we only have maybe
about a thousand items on this site but
the museum itself has
thousands of items and they're not all
going to end up on this website
but so i'd say that relationship between
those two programs are pretty unique
um and it's definitely this is like you
know in terms of the combination of
functions that we put here it's very
very custom we definitely made use of
a certain pre-existing you know
wordpress functionalities
uh or functions to make this happen
thanks yeah i'm you know in a nutshell
without going into crazy detail
i'm trying to keep it pretty simple
other questions from from the group
[Music]
um
well i um so i'll i'll finally ask a
question
um and and it sort of goes back to the
the
um question about um you know the
choices that you're making in terms of
the story lines
um it seems like the story lines are you
know it sounds like they're quite
um labor-intensive and um
and you know each one
like you know just the one that you
showed
you know you can see how much care and
thought and time went into it
um and so i'm wondering about
you know over time you know do you see
how many of the story lines do you see
um creating and is this something that
would that you see as
as an ongoing project where you know
every
six months or something or every certain
amount of time
over the first few years you're
continuing to add
these stories or you know what's what's
that
that kind of longer term picture for the
storyline
aspect of the site
i don't know who wants to field that one
so right now we have plans for four uh
and the four i guess chris mentioned
them
it's the mexican uh american experience
it's the memorial day massacre
environmental challenges in the area and
activism which is a much more
contemporary story
and then de-industrialization which is a
historical story but
a little bit more recent history 80s and
90s
uh they are really labor intensive and
they require
essentially funding so um the
we got a supplemental grant from another
foundation to do
a couple of additional ones which is why
we now have plans for four
and i think doing more is kind of a
wonderful idea
but also requires requires funding um
one of the things that that again we
wanted to do was
find other ways to weave stories into
the archive which is why the back
stories
which are much more you know much less
labor intensive
the featured curations uh and then a
third
uh sort of direction which jeff could
talk about if he if we have time
uh something we call stor um story lines
which are
um or i'm sorry story paths which
which is a little bit like a story line
what you saw
but much lighter in terms of the the
design
elements the design work and the sort of
shaping of
an arc i know jeff do you want to
briefly describe that yeah briefly i
mean because i guess
you know the interesting thing and
that's kind of having these kind of two
sections of storylines in the archive
and then being related is that um this
idea of kind of pushing the archive a
little bit in terms of his storytelling
capabilities
is that we were kind of coming up with
things that were making it lean a little
bit towards the storyline side but not
go like
full-on into it they still are kind of
these separate spaces
but yeah story paths and i know we keep
using the word story in like a lot of
different ways so we might
have to change the name we're kind of
worried about you know
storylines yeah there's a lot of
different forms of story
uh but with the divine story path is
that instead of it you know curations
are kind of just like a
collective group of items that kind of
fit under uh you know a shared theme
but a story path would be kind of like
you're
thoughtfully kind of choosing a sequence
of items in the collection
that might uh if you were to follow it
in sequence actually have some kind of
an interesting arc to them
uh and it would almost be almost like a
like in my mind it's almost like an
automatic or something it's like this
kind of visual storyboard
or something you could follow and if you
if you go from like picture to picture
to picture
you can actually see this visual
narrative kind of unfolding
uh and that's like one other way to kind
of pump up the storytelling capability
of the archive itself
yes yeah something entertaining yeah the
story lines with the complicated ones
you know we start with essentially
what's an animatic you know it could be
a powerpoint or a google doc or
something
so this would be yeah like a stripped
down
version of that without you know
designed
you know because it would be based on a
nice design but not custom designed i
think
um right the other you know sound design
and and stuff that really takes a lot of
the effort and energy and
time and it kind of kind of invites the
user uh to fill in the gaps themselves a
little bit or kind of do a little bit
more of the investigating themselves
uh you know so we're just kind of
providing the the main kind of key
frames
and they can kind of choose to read up
more about the individual items and kind
of fill in the
narrative gaps a little bit on their own
um
so yeah i think the whole the whole idea
is right so you have the archive
the archive is the thing and i mean i
always think of it i always think kind
of archive first right it's an archive
and you can explore the archive in a lot
of different ways
and maybe it seems confusing that there
are a lot of sort of story
story story ways of of exploring it
but i feel like really it's an archive
and once you get into the archive then
you can discover
oh my gosh you know like there's a
featured curation or you know there's a
story path
this item leads to that item uh this one
has a backstory
uh or you can go and just embrace the
full-on
storylines as well however many of those
there end up being
so so it's an archive first and then
we're trying to make all these internal
connections
that supplement and enhance and as i was
saying you know
bring out the stories behind the objects
hopefully not in a confusing way where
you know you don't really understand
what you're doing
you're seeing because what you're seeing
is an archive
yeah and i just wanted to briefly say
like in terms of
again this has taken enormous amount of
work i think far more than any of this
um us anticipated when we got involved
with it so i just wanted to give a huge
shout out to jeff who's done um really
extraordinary work
um and you know and making it look
really
gorgeous at the same time i've been also
seeing kurt found up there like
current helped back in the early days of
thinking about this project so thank you
thank you kurt
and just mentioning some other folks
like in addition our car our archivist
has done
enormous amounts of work again like you
know taking the community attic and
trying to get it all organized
and the director of the museum who's a
volunteer guy who's been volunteering
for many years
um you know he you know like every item
we're constantly going to him and like
what do you know about this rod we can't
find any information
and like just just an extraordinary
amount of work and over
decades that he put into kind of
preserving these these items and making
sure that they're they're kind of around
that there's information on them so
anyway so i just wanted to give a you
know again a recognition of how much
this has been
an enormous team effort um
you know and you can see why people
you know you know why there probably
hasn't been a lot like this
it's just an enormous amount of work um
to do this kind of thing and
you know um any anyway but you know
so it's been it's it's it's been great
we'll see
um we'll see how it goes but it is a
huge team effort
um to do something like this
um so we've gone past time but um
uh i think there's there's one other
question
from tomas in the q a um
if if you have a moment for for that and
it's a question about the the platform
um why wordpress versus other archives
specific platforms like omeca
oh thank you professor but i think he
largely responded by now so
okay all right thank you so much
okay i think um i think uh
time our time is has come to an end but
um this has been really incredible and
and
um really it's such a rich rich project
um and you're doing such um
you know beautiful work with it you know
and you know that's both meaningful
and aesthetically beautiful so um
i want to thank you for presenting and
and um
ask everyone else to join in in giving
your thanks
giving thanks
thanks thank you all so much it's been
great to have a chance to talk about the
project with you all so thank you yeah
thank you
yeah thanks for joining all right take
care everyone